now to my other family my musical family
during the hardest year of my life all
they always dare to check on me and push
me up and I want to tell you I
appreciate that
I love that and and I wouldn't be here
if I didn't get those messages and I
want to thank everybody here from the
bottom of my heart you know that really
cared about me and and we are a musical
family and we and we have to be there
for each other and now because we are a
family I have to be honest you know for
the last two days I've been conflicted
you know I'm being honored by the
industry that I love the family that I
love but there's an elephant in the room
and it's not just about the Grammys this
discrimination and injustice everywhere
an all-time high but there's something I
need to say to the Grammys and and I
changed my name to my middle name the
love so it's showing love combs now and
I didn't you have to call me a different
name is to add it on name if you want to
call me love so I say this with love to
the Grammys because you really need to
know this every year
y'all be killing us man man I'm talking
about the pain I'm speaking for all the
artists here to producers the executives
the amount of time that it takes to make
these records to pour your heart out
into it and you just want to even
playing field and the great words the
Erykah Badu we are artists and we are
sensitive about our we are passionate
for most of us this is all we got this
is our only hope
truth be told hip hop has never been
respected by the Grammys black music has
never been respected by the Grammys to
the point that it should be
so so right now there's this current
situation it's not a revelation this
thing been going on and it's not just
going on in music is going on a film is
going on in sports is going on around
the world and for years we've allowed
institutions that have never had our
best interest at heart to judge us and
that stops right now
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm I'm officially starting a clock
y'all got 365 days to get this together
we need the artists to take back to
control
we need transparency we need diversity
this is the room that has the power to
make the change that needs to be made
they have to make the changes for us
their nonprofit organization that is
supposed to protect the welfare of the
musical community that's what it says on
on a mission statement that's the truth
they work for us we have the power we
decide what's hard if we don't go nobody
goes we don't support nobody supports we
control what was cool we control was hot
we control your kids listen to what they
dance to we control with some video
games we control how they with a pants
sag they pens we control everything now
we're not gonna solve this tonight but
it's going to take all of us to get this
done it's gonna take the artists and
executives to recognize their power and
I'm standing here today not to just
Badshah because as I said y'all
nonprofit organization we just need to
get it right and I'm here for the
artists so sign me up I'm here I'm here
to help make a difference and help us
have a positive outcome and I believe
all my brothers and sisters out there
would be willing to work on getting this
right because we just want it right we
just want to be able to go to the
Grammys you got to understand we seen
we've seen Quincy Jones and Michael
Jackson Michael J's was holding eight
Grammys he was dropping the Grammys but
you know why he was dropping the Grammys
why he got eight Grammys because they
never nominated him for off-the-wall
and so brillo was his revenge it wasn't
his honest work
it was his revenge he was like y'all
wanna put me I'm going I'm gonna take
your souls and then we had thriller my
goal used to be about making hit records
now is about ensuring that the culture
moves forward my culture our culture the
black culture and for me to be worthy of
receiving our icon award I have to use
my experience to help make a change and
on that note I'm finishing up y'all got
365 days and I want to dedicate this
award to Michael Jackson for
off-the-wall prints for 1999 Beyonce for
lemonade Missy Elliott for the real
world Snoop Dogg with doggy style
[Applause]
Kanye West for graduation
hey or and nas for illmatic I love y'all
[Music]